monsieur federowski bonsoir
bonsoir
racontez-moi l'est presque sans michael
gorbatchev il y aurait eu
[Musique]
fin de la guerre froide glace noces
pérestroïka cette tentative de réforme
importante de du socialisme et de l'urss
pourquoi tentative gorbatchev reste en
germes du 20e siècle c'est en quelqu'un
qui a contribué à une grande percée vers
la liberté à hautmont d'équilibré
c'était une chance historique pour les
russes de réformer leur pays mais aussi
pour les occidentaux de créer un monde
équilibré je pense que son départ c'est
un moment aussi nous rend service
presque avec ça
sa dernière phrase laisse qui nous a
prévenus que le monde n'était jamais si
près de la guerre mondiale si près de
l'apocalypse nucléaire
aujourd'hui on est prêt de sa
responsabilité de ça vous savez bien
avec mes origines craignent âge était
toujours critique envers poutine mais
c'est pas seulement ça c'est le fait que
l'occident n'a pas saisi cette chance
autrefois dans le post communisme qu'il
a trahi les promesses leur voiture
notamment de l'otan tout ça ça comme ça
a contribué à la crise que nous vivons
qui est une crise absolument terrible
les russes des textes juridiques aux
voitures mais ça ne veut rien dire il
restera un personnage de l'espoir
simplement tout le système qu'on a
construit le système d à court d
équilibre des intérêts n'existe plus en
plus je pense que l'équilibré des
intérêts c'est un mot qui nous tombons
qui doit revenir à ça arrêtez je parle
aux ruches mais aussi aux occidentaux
arrêtés c'est posture va-t-en-guerre
chercher la paix et pas pour la guerre
par la guerre c'est ça le message de
barbe action je reviens sur une des
choses que vous avez dit il a tendu la
main il a cherché la paix la dr gagner
le nobel de la paix faut le rappeler
quand même mais il s'est senti trahi en
voyant que l'ouest l'otan
grignotait trop de ce territoire de
l'ancienne l'ancienne urss alors non pas
qu'il regrettait son geste de paix mais
il s'est dit c'est ça devait pas être
comme ça n'est ce pas
évidemment - l'occident s'est il ne faut
pas sous-estimer le rôle de la bêtise
occident vous savez dans le politique
vous savez il suffit de regarder la
télévision que vous représentez si bien
regarder la télévision et comparer les
gens qu'on y fera en cause ou c'est bien
connu ni chirac en france les vôtres
les gens des américains tout ça il
comprenait ça avec les gens
d'aujourd'hui le message de gorbatchev
c'est le message de recherche de la paix
de l'église libre des intérêts c'est pas
du tout le message des va-t-en-guerre et
vous savez vraiment la médiocrité de la
période actuelle saute aux yeux alors
avec son départ regardons dans le miroir
recherchons la paix et par la diact
monsieur fédorovski il ya des gens qui
changent le cours de l'histoire par
leurs actions que chez elle je le j'en
parle souvent c est ce que il avait le
choix de faire ce qu'il a fait est ce
que c'est par volonté par courage par
ténacité qu'il est arrivé à prendre
cette chance là de dire je vais serrer
la main à l'auxerrois ouest je vais donc
bâtir ce pont vers la paix vers la fin
de la guerre froide est ce que son rôle
personnel a été
important primordial évidemment regardé
ces images de trudeau grand train de
regarder mon ami yakovlev à côté qui
était ambassadeur au canada inventeur de
la pérestroïka
regarder ces gens là réfléchissez un
tout petit peu et vous posez monsieur en
question très très grave c'est sa
volonté qui a changé les choses ça
aurait pu dû et encore des années avec
l'urss il a ma femme dit à l'époque
gorbatchev elle a tendu la main à
l'occident avec le coeur l'occident a
pris le coeur il a réfuté la main et on
paie très cher avec ce qui se passe je
voudrais pas revenir aux spectateurs
vous comprenez vous ne le faites pas
heureusement mais beaucoup de gens en
occident mélange la propagande de la
politique réelle poutine une large la
politique que la première propagande de
la politique ray gorbatchev ne le
faisait jamais et c'est pour ça qu'il
restera comme en géant du 20e siècle gco
j'ai eu la chance de connaître jean paul
ii jean paul ii lui c'est un message
pour la paix très vite à madrid opère
aussi on n'oublie pas très bien monsieur
poutine se sert de ce déclin de l'empiré
comme étant un moteur idéologique dans
sa guerre en ukraine dans quelle mesure
gorbatchev ne lui a pas donné l'occasion
de d'aller à fond dans cette théorie de
la revanche
non la théorie de la relance ou bleu
vous savez je vais vous dire il faut pas
construire et narratif
c'est pas la théorie de la revanche
poutine reflète une grande blessure de
l'opinion publique qui a pensé qu'il
était prêt à 80% d'aller vers l'occident
il s'est senti trahi dans ses
dispositions et poutine évidemment se
construit quelque chose en sa faveur
pour la propagande mais vous comprenez
leur voiture ce n'est pas le seul faty
fautif on dit souvent qu'il était laïc
je tiens à vous dire c'est être
quelqu'un qui était volontaire et
simplement il était aussi il a eu une
sorte de volonté orientée vers l'avenir
on n'a pas saisi cette chance pour l'en
dans le moment de pause communisme je
pense que ce dernier service qui nous a
rendus qu'il apprenait que le monde
aujourd'hui est au bord de l'apocalypse
réfléchissons ça éloignons nous de la
propagande et je tiens à vous dire vous
qui êtes un grand journaliste et vous ne
faites jamais mais hélas non seulement
poutine mais le journalisme occidentale
tombe aujourd'hui dans la propagande
éhontée très bien quelques secondes
avant de vous laisser aller me suffit de
rose qui il a aussi avec la glace noces
il a fait libérer des gens il a mis plus
de liberté dans la société à l'époque ça
ce n'est pas rien non plus le faut quand
même le souligner il
vit d'abord vous dites il a vu plus que
la liberté vous savez que la liberté de
la presse c'était unique dans l'histoire
de la russie ce sourire voiture ça n'a
jamais existé comme ça et je tiens à
vous dire que aujourd'hui on assiste à
quelque chose de très grave moi je vis
en occident et je ressens profondément
non seulement avec poutine là
je la liberté de la presse est
verrouillé mais je tiens à vous dire ici
en occident nous avons grand problème
d'audit de la dictature du politiquement
correct le message de barback sûr c'est
de sortir de ça ou à revoir les vrais
enjeux le vrai enjeu aujourd'hui le vrai
enjeu c'est la paix la paix la recherche
de la paix tient par très bien dehors
des sages dans des sages qui suggère ou
jeffrey sachs aux états unis voilà il
visite les leçons de gorbatchev elles
sont aussi importantes pour
poutine que pour l'occident que pour
l'ouest également lundi mire federowski
on va se reparler parce que bientôt on
va se reparle en voir faire le point sur
cette guerre en ukraine ensemble je sais
pas quand mais on va le faire bientôt
nous allons donner comme relais parce
que vous savez je tiens à vous dire
aussi revenir comme je suis en craignant
je vais vous dire vous savez l'intérêt
de l'ukraine c'est pas la mode peut dire
que son nez dans l'impasse personne
cherche la guerre que l'on recherche la
paix aujourd'hui nous comprenez on est
dans le va-t-en-guerre dans tous les
côtés et avec mon expérience puisque
j'ai participé comme fossoyeur de but de
communisme
et de la guerre froide à ce processus je
tiens à vous dire il faut être très
pointue dans l'analyse très bien
longtemps gelé éviter les approximations
on tentera de lettres merci beaucoup
comme toujours à bientôt